[Music]
ever wondered how growing startups are
leveraging google cloud database
services stay tuned to find out more hi
everyone i'm jolene thiel and i'm a
customer engineer at google cloud and
welcome back to the google cloud
technical guides for startups where we
are creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to help startups to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on google
cloud in our previous episode we covered
networking configurations and moving on
to today's episode episode 7 of the
series we will be going through
databases with a focus on cloud sql
for today we're going to first go
through the big picture on databases and
when to choose which we'll then deep
dive into cloud sql and also run through
a demo on cloud sql as well as how it
interacts with some of the other
services in google cloud i'll then share
with you some tips and tricks around
cost as well as performance optimization
we'll then go through a sample
architecture as well as a customer
success story and then we'll finally
wrap up with some links you can go
through with after this video alright so
let's get started let me give you an
overview on how google cloud can help
you with your database needs
as you can see there is a full suite of
database services available to meet your
different requirements over here you can
see highlights of each type from
in-memory to relational to
non-relational as well as what each
service is good for
not only do we have our google build
cloud native database services where you
can use mysql or postgresql for ease of
migration and compatibility we also do
support traditional databases such as
sql server
and finally to complete the portfolio we
also work very closely with our partners
such as mongodb confluent and many more
to provide you with that integrated
support at this point you must be
wondering how do you go about choosing
which database service then well i've
got your back
here is a flowchart to help you out with
your startup's database service decision
making depending on your application you
might need one or several of these
services available
now because many startups leverage sql
databases for the transactional
processing in their applications which
cloud sql supports today we're going to
zoom into database configurations with
cloud sql
building running and maintaining
infrastructure means less time creating
value for your app run the same
relational databases that you know
without the hassle of self-management
this frees up time for you to focus on
building great applications for your
startup cloud sql is a fully managed
database service where google takes care
of the administrative tasks required to
run a database making it easy for you
and simple to operate
cloud sql also has full compatibility
with mysql postgresql and sql server
with cloud sql you can easily create
read replicas and backups and there is
also automatic failover ensuring that
your database will always be available
when you need it
cloud sql also offers easy integration
with just about any application from
google kubernetes engine to compute
engine and many more open up analytics
possibilities with cloud sql's native
integration with bigquery where bigquery
can directly query from your cloud sql
databases running federated queries
enabling you to not need to move your
data
cloud sql resides in secure google data
centers ensuring business continuity
with reliable and secure services backed
by a 24 7 sre team with a 99.95
sla there is also automatic data
encryption at rest and in transit
you can also easily migrate your
databases to cloud sql with minimal
downtime using the database migration
service
lastly monitor and troubleshoot with
cloud sql insights which is a simple and
open tool that can help developers to
understand database performance issues
on cloud sql
maintenance is also very easy with
automated patching
to dive a little deeper with cloud sql
databases cloud sql supports read
replicas and cross region read replicas
you can leverage replication to
horizontally scale your application
needs to highlight you can leverage
cross-region read replicas for disaster
recovery cloud sql also has a built-in
high availability option which helps you
to reduce downtime when a zone or
instance becomes unavailable with high
availability your data will still
continue to be available to client
applications
cloud sql also provides you with both
automated and on-demand backups with
point-in-time recovery backups help to
protect your data from loss or damage
you can create a backup anytime you want
on demand and this could come in really
handy when you may be about to perform a
risky operation on your database
you can also enable automatic backups
where possible schedule your backups
where your instance has the least
activity
right it's about time to give you a tour
on how it looks like now on to the demo
we are going to continue on with the
guestbook application demo in this demo
i'm going to show you how you can create
your cloud sql instances and then
populate them with data being imported
from cloud storage we'll then explore
some sql statements within cloud shell
and then we'll connect to bigquery as
well as data studio and last but not
least we'll wrap up with a connection to
google compute engine alright let's get
started for the first part of the demo
we'll be going through how to create
cloud sql instances now moving into the
console first we're gonna head over to
cloud sql and click on the create
instance button to create a new instance
you can easily configure your new
instance according to exactly how you
want it to be like
first you're gonna be prompted to select
your database engine over here you can
see the different options available and
for this demo i'm going to just select
postgresql next give your instance an
instance id and just remember that it
has to be unique within the project and
then following that put in a password
and following that you can also choose a
region to be either single zone or
multi-zone by default it's multi-zone
and you can select the zone for the
primary and failover instance if you do
not have specific requirements feel free
to leave it as any and on the right hand
column you can see a summary of the
different options and configurations you
have selected
at this point you can already create
your cloud sql instance if not you can
continue on to configure the advanced
configurations
you can select your machine type b
whether is it standard lightweight
shared course or high memory you can
also select the custom option to
uniquely make selections for your memory
as well as cores as for the storage type
the typical selection is ssd for lower
latency and higher throughput however
you can also make the selection and
switch over to hdd you can choose your
storage capacity or select custom if you
intend to go beyond 200gb at the same
time you can check to enable automatic
storage increases where if you run out
of space google will allocate additional
storage to you as for connections you
have options for public ip or private ip
in this case i'm just gonna go ahead to
select both
for automated backups you can select a
window of time for this to occur it
would be best to select the non-peak
hours of your business where there is
lower traffic to your sql instances
similarly for patching upgrades and
maintenance you can also select the
non-peak hours
and lastly you can also set up database
flags as well as make use of labels
which are really good for billing as
well as tracking where your costs are
coming from
all right and now we're good to go i'm
just gonna hit create and we're just
gonna speed up this part until the
instance is being created
all right our cloud sql instance is up
and running
moving on to the next section in this
demo i'm going to show you how you can
import data into your cloud sql instance
and we're also going to connect to it to
read the data in this case we will be
using guest data for this demo so first
we're going to create a database by
going over to the database tab
to create a new database called
guestbookdb
over here i have my cloud sql instance
and first i'm going to select import
which is the button right at the top
for source i'm going to select the sql
file that i've already imported into
cloud storage and this file is what's
going to be creating the tables for the
format i'm going to select sql and also
include the destination
and following that i'm going to repeat
this process to import the data to
populate those tables
in this part of the demo we're going to
be exploring the imported data using sql
statements in cloud shell now we're
going to connect to the sql instance via
cloud shell simply by selecting the
button connect using cloud shell
enter the command to connect and
authorize
and we're going to speed this part up a
little bit as well and then following
that also enter in your password to
connect
from here we can now run a couple of
queries so first we can list the
databases
and then we can select one
and finally we can then list perhaps the
guess
all right and we are done now i'm gonna
show you how to connect to bigquery and
data studio
right so first move to the bigquery page
add external data source and then select
your connection type in this case i'm
just gonna go ahead and select postgres
and then give it a name
select your location over here i'm just
gonna go ahead with u.s central one and
then following that copy and paste your
cloud sql instance id
enter in the password as well and then
click to create the connection
you should also see the connection being
created in the left navigation menu
alright and from here you can just start
querying in this example query itself
you can see the external query function
as well as the connection id and this
makes it very easy for you to query
directly from cloud sql within bigquery
for running federated queries easily on
top of data analysis in bigquery you can
also easily create a connection to data
studio for data visualization there are
many connectors available as you can see
over here and for this demo we're going
to select the postgres connector
and then we're going to create a new
report
from here you can easily add charts and
i'm just gonna speed up this part and
show you the end result of how
visualization can look like for you
all right and we're done here is a
sample dashboard to show you how you can
use data visualization in connection to
cloud sql with data studio
and finally in this demo section i'm
going to show you how you can connect
cloud sql back with google compute
engine
all right so now we're going to head
over to google compute engine and then
we're going to ssh in to set up the
cloud sql proxy so first we're going to
make sure that there are permissions by
uploading the service account key that
has both the cloud sql client as well as
edit roles
next we'll then download the cloud sql
off proxy
and also make the cloud sql auth proxy
executable
we will then install the postgresql
client onto the compute engine instance
and then start the postgresql auth
proxy and finally you can connect to the
psql client
and following that you can already begin
to start querying we're going to run a
couple of queries similar to earlier
before to show you the connection
all right it looks awesome and we're
done
now that you know how to configure your
cloud sql database i'll be sharing with
you some of the best practices for cost
as well as for performance optimization
we will be going through some of the top
tips and i'll also put some links in the
description box below for your further
reading
for performance optimization first of
all do consider a micro services
architecture sometimes known as vertical
sharing
this refers to having multiple smaller
databases for each microservice you may
have as compared to having one monolith
database for all of your services which
can help you to increase and optimize
your performance
remember that this is a general
suggestion and perhaps in specific
architectures a monolithic architecture
may work for you
secondly for your read heavy workloads
do remember to add read replicas to
offload traffic from your primary
instance
optionally you can also make use of a
load balancer like ha proxy to manage
traffic to your replicas
lastly use good connection management
practices such as exponential back-off
and connection pooling
using these techniques will help you to
improve your applications use of
resources and also to stay within the
cloud sql connection limits
as for costs the cloud sql idle instance
recommender helps to detect instances
that might be idle it then provides you
with recommendations and insights on how
you can reduce costs
next the cloud sql over-provisioned
instance recommender helps to detect
instances that are unnecessarily large
for a given workload
it then provides you with some
recommendations on how you can resize
these instances
lastly do leverage commit use discounts
which are ideal for predictable
workloads on a one year or three year
basis which can give you significant
cost savings now let's explore some of
the use cases involving cloud sql as you
can see over here cloud sql works across
many use cases from gaming to inventory
management and many more next let's zoom
into one example a sample fictitious
gaming backend database architecture
here we can see all of the different
databases in action first we have cloud
firestore a nosql document database
which can be used for authentication as
well as the player database cloud memory
store is then used for storing regional
in-memory caches which speeds up the
access to frequently viewed data
cloud sql or cloud spanner then helps
with the hosting of the game data
you can also log events to cloud
bigtable google cloud's nosql columnar
database and finally you can also
connect to bigquery for data warehousing
and gameplay analytics
and if we wanted to take a look at a
real-life example we have crite crikey
is a mobile ar gaming startup that
leverages on google cloud to bring
diversity into the mobile ar gaming
space
qrikey migrated the cloud sql and also
uses some of the other google cloud
services which has helped them to reduce
the rendering time for customers and
also increase the speed of crikey games
using cloud sql has helped crikey to
decrease the load time of videos improve
the speed of games resulting in higher
ad engagement times
all in all i hope that this video has
given you a good understanding of google
cloud database services and how you can
get started on cloud sql
and after this video if you are still
keen to find out more and cannot get
enough of databases and cloud sql do
check out the links in the description
box below in our next episode you will
be learning all about firebase we'll
first kick off with an overview of what
firebase is how you can build better
applications improve application quality
as well as drive user engagement will
then go through a demo as well as a
customer success story alright and
that's a wrap see you in the next video
[Music]